and it's like no different than any
other business you know opening a
restaurant what do you think your
customer base is going to be and how
many meals you're going to sell
you know building a condominium complex
what's the revenue going to be it's just
like that maybe a little less
predictable than that because it's a
movie
how do you articulate distribution and
sales forecasts to investors
well articulate them i show them charts
and basically i show them what i believe
the revenue
generation is going to look like over
what period of time which is the cash
flow analysis and then i put it into a
nice concise chart so that they can see
it in sort of a one page that's how i
articulate it now how do i create it
i do my own sales forecast because i
have enough distribution experience to
sort of know what to expect what the
levels are what people are paying it
changes all the time obviously because
as the market develops and as new
customers come in or different
technology whatever so you have to
constantly keep revisiting that
but you generally do a revenue forecast
based on either
comparable movies that have
gone in the past not too far in the past
that you can compare to
based on your own experience based on
what you believe you're going to get
from a certain marketplace
and you do them at i do what five
different levels like low
semi low medium medium high high so i do
five levels some people do ten levels
some people do three levels you know you
can't do you could do one level but you
know it's
so i show what sort of the
average that we can expect is what you
know the home run is what the disaster
is
and um
but a lot of people pay for that so
there's companies that that you can buy
revenue forecasts from that do it for
you know as a service and you pay a lot
of money actually
i've seen lots of those forecasts
i
don't think they're so credible but you
need something you got to show something
to investors to say that you've done
your homework and this is what a
credible company that has compared it to
sort of like movies
has shown the reason i don't think
they're so credible is
several reasons one is they're using
movies that have played like 10 years
ago they can't they're talking home
video numbers home video doesn't even
exist anymore you know so they're
comparing
completely different technologies and
release patterns
two is they're usually using
movies that are bigger at budgets
than what an indie film would be so you
know like they're comparing my movie to
home alone
hello i mean they're not even in the
same league they're different businesses
you know so but you know it's family
audience and this and that type of thing
so i just
i'm
so so financially
um response like i'm not respon i'm
responsible but but i'm i'm i'm so
critical financially i i gotta make sure
that it makes sense and sometimes
the the comps as they call the
comparables are not as credible as you
know when you talk to say a sales rep
who is in the market right now
who deals with today's audience and
today's platforms and you sit them down
and say
what do you think
and it doesn't matter what 10 movies did
10 years ago what matters is what they
think because they're out there
interacting with customers all the time
and selling movies to them
now i also have relationships with some
agents and distributors around the world
so i'm able to call them up and say okay
what do you think and nobody gives
definitive answers they give well it
could be this it could be that it could
be at least you get a ballpark and it is
a ballpark but you say to your your
investors you know here's the ballpark
here's the range
you know
it could be a big range you know and
here's what you think the target's going
to be and it's like no different than
any other business you know opening a
restaurant what do you think your
customer base is going to be and how
many meals are you going to sell
you know building a condominium complex
what's the revenue going to be it's just
like that maybe a little less
predictable than that because it's a
movie
do you talk to your students at ucsd
about that i mean do they want to know
how can i create this even if it's just
for play and excel yeah they do but it's
so i'd need a whole course on that
actually um it's so extensive first of
all
you have to understand finances a little
bit too and and i do get into i said i
mentioned cash flow you see so there's
how much revenue you're going to
generate but what the time frame it's
going to take to generate it and that
speaks to sort of return on investment
or internal rate of return so for
instance if you invested say a thousand
dollars in in today and next year i gave
you back two thousand dollars you would
have gotten you know 100 return on your
you know
or 200 roi like double your money right
but over a year
but if if i returned it to you two years
later it would have been over two years
so it's a sort of a different
financial analysis for an investor
because they're looking at their annual
rate of return so the longer it takes to
return the money the lower their return
on investment has been or their internal
rate of return as we call it this is
beyond what film students want to learn
i mean film students don't sign up to
learn this is accounting stuff i mean
this is stuff you learn in business
school
you know there's finance right so i
don't get i talk about it but i don't
get into too much depth but ironically
we just finished that unit on
distribution and part of the assignment
they have to do an assignment part of
the assignment is doing a very very high
level cursory
revenue forecast and everybody said how
would we know how to do that and i said
just guess
and they said what's the point i said
you'll understand the point in five
years from now just guess okay and the
point of that exercise if my students
watch this video is that
they have to go through the motions to
look at the different sort of revenue
streams
vod television international so so now
they're considering what revenue streams
there are and they're just putting
numbers in it doesn't matter what the
numbers are it's the format of what they
have to think about the numbers don't
matter today because they're going to
change tomorrow and in 10 years or five
years when they go to do their films
they'll be a whole different marketplace
with maybe some different categories
it's just the concept of going through
the motions to understand how to set it
up
that's what matters
and once they turned in those
assignments and you talked about it as a
group i'm assuming maybe you did maybe
you didn't what was their impression
of the revenue forecast right so they
had to create and even they're just
plugging in these numbers and they're
just maybe guessing the revenue forecast
is a tiny tiny component the major
component of the assignment was
marketing was how to create awareness it
was well it was basically
deciding who your audience so each
everybody picked a film to use some
people pick some of my films some people
you they got to they had to choose a
feature film
this is what they do then they have to
tell me who their audience is and why
then they have to tell me how they're
going to create awareness with that
audience so which is a whole marketing
campaign like what they're going to do
with social media they're going to do
paid advertising how much they want to
spend and why they can justify that
spend
then they're going to tell me what
platforms how they're going to make it
accessible to the audience are they
going to do a theatrical release are
they going to do you know video on
demand are they going to try to do
subscription if so what do they expect
is their return so they have to do all
the research on all the platforms and
what to expect will they do television
afterwards will they do day and date
releases this kind of stuff that's the
core of it now how much they're going to
make is literally a separate course i do
that i do two things sort of as add-ons
which are worth fewer points everything
is point-based
um sort of how much what the revenue
would be and and the other thing is do a
distribution agreement
so i give them a template for a full
distribution agreement so they can read
it and see it and then i give them a
distribution memo and again they say
well how would we know this and i say
you won't just make it up because i
don't care what they say as the like the
term of the deal i care that they know
here's the items that go into a
distribution agreement you have to know
the territory the term the language you
know is it exclusive you know what the
payouts gonna be what it
i just care that they look at the
categories it doesn't matter what the
numbers are it's funny to read the
numbers because they're all over the
place but it doesn't matter it's the
thought process that goes into
understanding what goes into one of
these documents